kind enough to join us on short notice
because we don't know what we're talking
about what Johnny Manziel he was
suspended but the NFL was pretty close
lip on this did he fail a drug test Mike
well anytime there's a four-game
suspension under the substance abuse
policy Dan the most obvious conclusion
is that he failed multiple tests and now
it takes four or five failed substance
abuse tests before you end up getting
suspended so that is a fair assumption
and regardless of how he got here the
thing to keep in mind once you're
suspended four games you are smack dab
in the thick of the program you have
multiple drug tests per month
unannounced that you have to pass you
have a treatment plan that you must
respect dot every I cross every T and
the next time you make a mistake it's a
10-game suspension and the next time
after that you make a mistake positive
test failure to comply with your plan
etc it's a banishment for life with the
ability to apply for reinstatement after
one year so if he's serious about
getting back into the NFL this has put
up or shut up time because you're going
to have to comply with the letter of his
treatment plan he's going to have to
produce not positive but negative urine
samples on demand and if he fails in any
way he's going to be closer and closer
to being out for good but he's also
looking at another suspension I have to
believe Mike if he signs with another
team right well you get the personal
conduct policy in play as a result of
the pending assault charges in Texas and
remember the NFL no longer sits back on
a first offense and waits to see what
the criminal justice system does and
defers if there's just probation or a
diversionary program and they'll issue a
small fine or a limited suspension like
they did with Ray Rice it used to be
repeat offenders were the ones that got
the harsh treatment now you can do
something bad enough the first time that
you're going to get a suspension on top
of it then I can't imagine at this point
any NFL team no trusting this guy the
Browns trusted and not once but twice
they trusted him when he was doing the
Eddie Haskell routine in 2014 before the
draft oh he's all about football he's
you know he's he's straightened out he's
going to be fine and then it all blew up
and then he was in rehab for 10 weeks
last year they trusted him again and
blew up again I can't imagine any NFL
team out there at a position like
quarterback would roll the dice on
Johnny Manziel no matter what he does
going forward one other thing I was just
talking to mclovin about this I talked
to somebody yesterday who said you guys
were making a big deal over Andrew Luck
salary that it's actually a
team-friendly contract is that possible
with Andrew Luck well it is I mean even
though it's the biggest contract in NFL
history Dan you look at where the
quarterback markets been the last few
years it hasn't gone up much above 20
million a year luck gets about 23 for 23
5 it should be north of 25 million
easily when you consider where the
salary cap is and you also have to
consider what luck would have gotten if
he had said I don't want your six-year
contract he was going to make 16 million
this year he would have made about 25
million next year under the franchise
tag 30 million a year after that 43
million a year after that he traded four
years and about 114 million for six
years and 139 and at the end of that for
years he would have been on the open
market and some team swoops in and gives
him a contract that really would have
been shocking Jim Irsay said it was
going to be a shocking deal it's a
cookie cutter deal nothing shocking
about it at all the only thing
surprising is he didn't hold out to get
more money thank you Mike have a good
weekend all right that's Mike Florio pro
football time the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience